- I actually, I love fortune cookies.
Me and my eight-year-old
daughter love them.
We're obsessed with them.
So do you wanna open some
new fortune cookies together?
- Yeah. Yes.
- [Kelly] See what, what we get?
Okay.
- Do you do the rule where you have to
eat it first and then read the fortune?
- Oh my God.
I thought you were gonna say the rule
that's not a children appropriate, but.
- Oh no, I don't know that one. At all.
- No. You know, like
you put in the bedroom
at the end of every.
- Oh, no, I don't know that.
- What?
Like, you read it
and then it's like in the bedroom.
- Oh yes, yes, yes.
- Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay, we're opening.
- My rule is you have to eat a little bit
of the cookie before you read it.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay. Okay.
- Otherwise it won't come true.
- [Kelly] What if you
don't like the fortune?
- Well, that's just too bad.
(audience laughs)
- Okay.
- And mine says.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Oh. Mine's pretty good.
- Mine is too.
- "You will be the next
in line for a promotion".
(audience cheers)
- Congratulations.
- Yeah. I'm really excited.
- Thanks so much. What's yours?
- Mine is "The only way to
have a friend is to be one".
- [Christina] Oh, that is good.
- I love that.
Be what you want.
Yeah. I might keep that in my phone.
- I'm actually gonna keep
this one in my phone.
- But don't talk to us about it.
- Yeah, exactly.
I don't care who talks
to me about this one.
Because I would like a promotion.